[Music]
this is the workplace where you don't
have to do anything to get paid and you
never get sacked it's a job for life but
it's not even a job as such it's been
called the best club in London even the
Elysian Fields by Disraeli you'll have
guessed by now I'm speaking of the red
benches in the other place
the House of Lords it's emerged that
last year expenses plus the daily
attendance allowance cost 23 million
pounds the day rate for merely signing
on is 323 pounds in 2017 members agreed
to cap the size of the Lord's to a
maximum of 600 yet the forthcoming
dissolution owners are expected to bloat
the second chamber to 834 be wigged and
mint members not all of whom make a
substantial contribution to the work of
parliament the government has promised
reform even the Lords have voted to
reform I think members should serve a
five-year term their contribution should
be assessed and there should be a
mandatory retirement age they should be
titled but not entitled well before I
respond I want to make very serious
announcement that I love the sound of
the House of Lords so if anyone
influential is that I mean who wouldn't
want to be in there at that rate but I
actually think that the House of Lords
is is quite a jerk actually and I agree
with a lot of what you're saying so I
first of all I agree with the necessity
of a second chamber just a kind of
sanity check I so do i yes I think that
we need to have something I think what
we have in its current form has just
gone out of control I think it needs to
be slimmed down I don't think there
should be any hereditary peers at all I
think they should be fixed term I think
that there should be a cap in terms of
the amount of expenses or
or whatever you want to call it that you
can actually claim and I think that
there needs to be some form of to your
point cross-reference to how effective
are you being in this role because I
can't think of any other job where I
could just literally scan my pass
collects my screen does not quit and
then just sit there watching someone on
my phone or you know ticking boxes on
what you're doing then leave again and
I've got my money there has to be some
check that what you're doing is adding
value and that for me is a little bit
that's missing so I agree with you I
would like the house of Lord to exist
but in a very different format
apparently peers who made no
contribution at all last year picked up
in expenses over a million pounds let's
see what the House of Lords themselves
say the increase in the cost of House of
Lords allowances in 2018-19 financial
years largely due to a 25% increase in
the number of days the house sat rising
from 129 in 2017 18 to 161 in 2018 19 as
mirrors of Lords can generally only
claim allowances for days they attend
the house any increase in sitting days
is likely to produce an increase in the
cost of members allowances that's the
House of Lords I think it's an absolute
slam-dunk no brain or whatever you want
to say for the start of their five years
who's going to appoint them for that
that's what you haven't explained yet so
they do a five-year term did they still
get in by sort of grace and favour and
being very helpful to one prime minister
or let's be honest making a sizable
donations how they going to get there in
the first place and will we have our
editorial aproblem is that the
hereditary is when asked always vote to
keep the hereditary so the turkeys
aren't voting for Christmas at all I'm
not sure how you you achieve a five-year
term maybe what you have to do this is
the thing is you have to read you know
the Lords themselves are recognized as a
problem we're just committees here from
the Lib Dem P R Lord Tyler who's given a
even more disparaging set of remarks
about the House of Lords and what he
says is it's the best daycare center for
the elderly in London families can drop
his Lord or ladyship off and make sure
that staff will look after them really
well they're a nice meal subsidized
by the taxpayer Nick Navis news in the
afternoon in the chamber or in the
library that's her Nord Lord Tyler
himself is saying that it's complicated
but it's the second biggest chamber in
the world and it's partly hereditary and
it's overstuffed and it's also the
average age is 70 so obviously something
has to be done but what Rachel yeah no I
think you're right I mean only I think
only China has a bigger second chamber
France Spain India with a population of
over a billion people has a smaller
chamber so I think that an elected
second chamber is is the solution and I
think a few reasons for that one make it
smaller straight away to that kind of
accountability Michelle that you're
talking about and three just to widen it
out so it's not based on you know
cronyism and patronage so that people
who actually come from a diversity of
the country as well as a diversity of
skills and experience and bring
different things to the table if it were
on the basis of being elected then that
would bring in different people might
even get you okay okay somebody's got to
do this I know what's going to happen
the tweets will start flying oh yeah he
wants to see I may be entitled there is
a defense first of all they do say they
do some work they they make a lot of
changes to the legislation in 2019 they
made two thousand five hundred and
thirteen changes eight thousand odd
written questions one hundred
fifty-three reports but you see our
committees now in my company activity
doesn't necessarily mean impact so with
a little bit of thought but the truth is
there are people in the house of Lord
who brings something that you wouldn't
necessarily get in an elected chamber so
I'm just thinking for example of the
astronomer royal Lord race who is full
disclosure as a friend he's brain big as
the size of a planet one of the
cleverest people and his contribution to
debate
are ones that frankly are brilliant and
in everybody listens to him the minute
he stands up
I think the elected house won't bring
you that right if I would just criticize
what you said it would be I think if I
were thinking about this the first thing
I do is get rid of all of the ex MPs who
are just there because they were and I
would make more space for people who
bring some actual expertise there are no
scientists worth speaking of in the
House of Commons any scientists and
engineers in the relatively speaking
again in the upper house but we're in a
world what we need to news I would focus
on Europe you mentioned Lord Rees but I
mean I as far as I'm concern is over 80
so how would you do deal with the
retirement issue that well you're right
there's one one in six members of the
House of Lords 133 of them are over the
age of 81 you think you could do is you
could say this is the official
retirement age but the house might have
a procedure by which somebody who it
thinks is particularly valuable can stay
right I'm gonna end as I started no
subtle hints here I'm my I said at the
beginning and definitely want to be in
there if anyone's watching they can get
me in please do bring to it now there is
never a shortage of people spouting hot
air on Twitter for this week so around
brewing over something that usually
brings solidarity to the public nothing
gets us Brits hot under the collar like
our love for a good copper but it all
went to parts when newly appointed
Chancellor which is sooo not don't
Yorkshire tea into hot water this week
demonstrating that he's truly a mother
of the people rishi tweeted quick budget
prep brick making tea for the team
nothing like a good Yorkshire brew but
Tricia's tea of choice from God's own
country cause
storm in a teacup as people jumps on the
wagon wheel and assumed Yorkshire tea
were in on the publicity stunt but their
Twitter team had the response in the bag
explaining it's been a rough weekend
it's been pretty shocking to see the
determination some of us have had to
drag us into a political mud fight but
it's been lovely to see others speak up
for us we're so grateful to everyone
who's done that in a civil way but for
anyone about to vent their rage online
even to accompany please remember
there's a human on the other end of it
and try to be kind
so for reminding us it's not always wife
reaching boiling points Yorkshire tea we
hope everyone will take a leaf out of
your booger I thought it was a
particularly cosy picture from us for
this week but don't forget you can join
the debate by searching for the pledge
on Twitter or on the Sky News Facebook
page and if you want to listen to the
programme on the go just search for us
on Apple podcast
anything quite frankly thanks for
watching and we'll see you next time
[Music]
you